remember last year when three of the
Spice Girls promised us a reunion what
the world ever happened well I can
always dream though and et online flea
and Aguilera asked Baby Spice Emma
Bunton for an update what are the
chances that we could get another
reunion of some kind family oh my
goodness who knows I mean I would love
to do something I love working with my
girls it's a very very special time when
we're together but you know we're kind
of doing individual stuff at the moment
we've all got children so it's very hard
to tour because we are mummies but
personally for me I'd love to work the
girls again we have so much fun and
maybe in the future who knows
so we'll keep waiting for the Spice
Girls to give us what we want what we
really really want until then baby spice
is on the search for the next big boy
band but she's kind of got a crush on
one of her coworkers
were you a Backstreet Boys fan and have
you been fangirling a little bit over
mr. Nick Carter I was a huge fan of
Backstreet Boys but I think I've kept my
cool I've been trying to keep my cool
yeah it's funny because she's Baby Spice
and I guess I'm baby backstreet it
really is weird and you know we're two
blondes just sitting up there behind the
the judges boot in my head I sing a lot
of backstreet's back alright and that I
love him he's adorable back
joining Emma Nick and Timbaland is host
Rita Ora the 26 year old singer has her
eye on the cute contestants all these
little guys there are little heart
throbs I know you I have to hang out
with them the most
it's good I'm basically like splurt Eng
slash really want these guys to like be
my friends because I'm alone on a loser
look yeah these guys are cheeky they're
flirty they know where they're looking
and how to look are you getting some
winks Rita I am and I'm not mad at it
either it makes me feel good I don't
hate that
have fun Rita okay boyband debuts
tonight on ABC
[Music]